star 80 où l'histoire donc de deux
copains qui décide de monter une tournée
qui signera au stade de france 2 quand
part interprété par richard anconina
avec patrick timsit nous avons sur ce
plateau déjà richard anconina bonsoir
bonsoir à vos côtés jean luc lahaye est
l'une des autres vedettes des années 80
et vedette de ce film bonsoir à vous à
l'accueil du public ici à saint quentin
en yvelines a l'air plutôt bon quand on
passe l'oreille on entend que le public
est plutôt réceptifs
vous êtes rassurés soulagés de voir que
le public adhère à star 80 ouais on est
on est rassuré depuis déjà deux
pratiquement deux mois parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a commencé une grosse tournée
france le 23 août parce qu'on a eu on a
présenté le film pour la première fois
au festival d'angoulême et ensuite on a
fait une très grande tournée france on a
montré le film dans beaucoup de villes
en france et le sait est unanime si à
chaque fois la même réaction du public
est très chaleureux très enthousiaste il
chantier de bougies pdi bruit il rigole
beaucoup et donc on n'est pas étonné qu
ici à saint quentin ce soit ce soit
équivalent ce soit la même chose la même
tonalité que que partout en france
moi j'étais plutôt habitué à rentrer
dans des salles feutrées
des gens concentrer sur un film avec
parfois quelqu'un qui fait du bruit en
toussant ou en mangeant des chips
biscuits détente en immédiatement champ
alors là je suis le mec est pas debout
sur son côté il passe pour un homme
mettez votre rôle pendant ce film
justement parce que les vedettes ce sont
ces stars des années 80 et vous en tant
qu'acteur vous étiez là pour les mettre
en valeur en fait oui le fils le film
mais c'est un hommage à ces gens là
à cette période à ce qu'ils ont parce
qu'ils ont installés pour très longtemps
dans la mémoire collective dans la
culture française en fin de la chanson
française
donc ils ont installé un truc très très
fort mon rôle moi ça c'est drôle je sais
pas j'ai pas bouger de ce que j'ai à
faire d'habitude dans mon métier j'ai eu
mon rôle d'acteur j'avais un personnage
à jouer d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que on
a fait le film avec patrick timsit c'est
pas un concert filmé c'est pas un
karaoké parce que ça n'allait pratique
parce que pas un karaoké
c'est pas con c'est un film et c'est pas
une télévision sur grand écran non ya
une chose qui est sûre c'est qu'on a
fait cette ce film là on l'a tous fait
pour la première fois moi je n'avais
jamais fait avant ainsi murray lui non
plus donc mettez connaissait d'ailleurs
déjà
en soirée on se croirait j'ai déjà
beaucoup d'estimé pour richard voilà un
croisé absolument donc sans on se disait
bonjour saluer mais j'avais sur richard
un regard bienveillant et je suis la
femme de son de son jeu et de son
capital c'est normal qu'ils aient à
regard bienveillant puisque je suis
tellement plus jeunes comment une chérie
tous là on accueille tout moment il
était tout petit quand j'achète 1983
justement cette chère aux pantins ce
sont deux césars qui vous ont été
décernés en 1983 richard anconina il
écoutait quoi j'ai écouté toutes ces
musiques là ont été payés de ces
musiques ont été entourées la voiture le
top 50
canal+ créé le top 50 avec l'arrivée de
la gauche jack lang kréol et les radios
fm et donc tous à toutes ces chansons là
était très présente et surtout on était
vraiment énorme support et beaucoup de
radios qui diffusent et c'est ces gens
là
enfin
simplement je te dis
fuster
je t'ai
feu qui brûle
hejda
vous me
réchauffer
parler de l'ambiance entre vous deux
justement de cette rencontre avec les
autres stars des années 80 comment s'est
passé le tournage est ce qu'il y avait
une concurrence en tout cas à l'image on
n'a pas l'impression non les mets mes
autres camarades artistes ont très vite
été une anxieux de devoir donner la
réplique à des comédiens comme richard
comédiens professionnels comme richard
et patrick 2 ultra ultra ultra motivés
de le faire et 3 avec un enthousiasme je
crois que très vite c'est devenu lé
richard et patrice ont de son parti de
la famille est alors je ne suis pas si
on fait partie de leur famille d'entre
eux font partie de notre famille est ce
que vous faites partie alors est ce qu
ils font partie de leur faites de votre
mieux rien et il ya quelque chose qui
est enfin c'est grâce à un truc c'est le
scénario le scénario tellement bon et
qu'on a tous des modes partition à jouer
on est content de notre partition quand
on arrive le matin on est content de ce
qu'on a à faire
voilà on aime l'histoire et tous ces
gens là aiment s m l histoire on l'a
tous aimé l'histoire donc ça
effectivement ça installe un climat
hyper favorable bienveillant des rondes
est content d'être là où on est on est
contente de venir le matin on est
content de se voir on a dépendantes se
charrier chérubins ambiance et en dehors
tout s'est bien passé vous avez d'abord
évidemment
jean lui fait dans la place
c'est pas parce que je joue mon
personnage que je vais être juste parce
que d'abord une vous découvrirez que les
personnages sont légèrement caricaturer
et justement je vous allez venir on
n'avait pas peur de la caricature ou
sinon je meurs de rien justement copé
mais pour pour pour la comédie pour
faire rire
voilà on épaissi le trait on grossit le
trait donc c'est ça ou ils sont forts ou
surtout est là partition d'aujourd'hui
qu'est est forte et l'abbé très bien
fait parce que c'est vrai que thomas
langmann s'est servie de style est bien
sûr avec beaucoup de respect et en en
parlant avec jean-luc mais il s'est dit
jean-luc il ay va y aller et il a joué
sur ce sur lui avec grossissant le trait
comme comme voilà il ya des gens qui ont
fait ça très bien dans la commune il a
assuré mais vraiment très bien avec la
bonne le bon curseur la bonne dose
grossir le trait en même temps il met de
la sincérité
il ya une très belle partition dans le
film et les très remarquée l'enfant pour
finir une toute dernière question le
plus grands tubes des années 80 pour
vous c'est quoi
nous avons connu la merci des femmes a
coûté cher parce qu'on s'attende à cette
réponse là dedans grands films des
années 80
j'aurais pu demander mais c'est gratuit
facile le plus grands tubes des années
80 alors je dirais que parce qu'il ya
une chanson marquante pour moi d'abord
laissé années 80 on n'en parle pas assez
mais c'est les années d'entre aide
humanitaire les grands mouvements
humanitaires
michael jackson
les mouvements anglais pour l'afrique lé
le sahel merveilleuse prise de
conscience avec tous les groupes pop les
plus gros pour monde donc pour moi la
plus grande chanson des années 80 reste
la chanson de michael jackson avec
il
m
ça c'est une chanson merveilleuses
mélodies tout cas on tout est résumé
dans cette chanson avec l'humilité de
toutes ces stars américaines qui
viennent
ce groupe est comme une équipe de foot
derrière michael qui est déjà au sommet
de sa gloire et tout le monde le fait
avec beaucoup de de tendresse et de
juillet mais en faire partie choix qui
n'aurait pas aimé c'est moi même toit
qui gérait des acteurs si effectivement
ça tombe bien sûr l'attention
j'aime autant vous demander de chanter
chantons